[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits
I'm link and I'm Rhett this week at the
round table of dim lighting we will be
exploring the question our magicians
actually cool mm-hmm I think this is an
important question I think that boy it
is and you know for for many years I
thought I knew the answer yeah and I
thought the answer was no but are you
but today based on this conversation
boiler alert I have new information that
has come to light via our shared
experience at a place called the Magic
Castle but you don't in which you have
an answer though I don't I don't think I
have an answer but I think I need to
talk this out yeah because it's not
nearly as simple as I thought it would
be we're gonna verbally process that
question yeah it is an important one
before we do I will say that as you're
listening to this it's you know we took
a three week break so welcome back to
the freshness of a totally new year
biscuit thank you for real istening to
some older ones over the past few weeks
but we are currently as you're listening
to this if you're listening to a fresh
we're in Australia we're doing the tour
of mythicality in Australia and if
you're curious what's going on with us
well you can look on Instagram and and
the other places where we're probably
posting things I imagine the future
probably the present listening us is
sharing our experience how's that for a
teaser we are probably posting stuff but
speaking of the tour of mythicality if
you want to experience us live on a
stage you can still do that November 8th
we're gonna be in Toronto Ontario hmm
that's Canada the Sony Center then
Friday November 9th are gonna be in
Atlantic City New Jersey at Caesars
Atlantic City Circus Maximus and then
Saturday November 10th we're gonna be in
oh goodness the Foxwood Resort Casino in
Connecticut so go to tour mythicality
calm there are still available tickets
for those they are moving pretty quickly
but if you want to we don't make it to
the Northeast very often this is
probably the only time that the tour
mythicality will be coming to that part
of the country
come see us so make it happen cabin and
we may we may have a magician there with
us I don't know it depends on this
conversation goes now
got a really good friend of ours Mike
who is following in our footsteps of
turning 40 yeah and say he's like I got
to do something
I gotta have a good 40th party and he
wanted to do something involving he
wanted to go to the like telescope
telescope but then that was booked Mount
Wilson you can have a party inside of a
telescope and it's actually pretty off
much more exciting than that sounded we
were really excited because I actually
toured these these telescopes with my
kids last year and thought to myself and
they were like you can have a birthday
party here and I was like mm-hmm I don't
even know anything about astronomy it's
I'm one of those guys who says astronomy
and astrology interchangeably okay
that's cool no I'm not
but there aren't you you know who you
are but it turns out it it was booked up
so we couldn't make that happen but it
also turns out that Mike's second
passion in addition to the far reaches
of the galaxy is the far reaches of
supernatural phenomenon in the form of
magic well I may be misrepresenting yes
his perception there I think he just
likes the thrill of being fooled because
he is a very knowledgeable guy about
pretty much everything and he knows the
secrets behind lots of magic tricks
okay he's read about them he's
fascinated but he likes to give himself
over to
the process of being amazed by magic and
the best opportunity for that to happen
in Los Angeles is the magic cast maybe
in the world I don't know I think it's a
pretty special place this Los Angeles
because it has a place called the Magic
Castle now we have so a whole group of
our friends we went to the Magic Castle
to celebrate his 40th birthday but just
to explain what the Magic Castle is if
you don't know basically in the heart of
Hollywood kind of up on this slope
there's a mansion it's not a castle it's
a mansion or I would say it kind of
looks like if you seen the Haunted
Mansion at Disneyland mm-hmm
now the house was just there but then at
some point it was bought by these people
who wanted to turn it into a private
magic club of course I guess decades ago
yeah decades so in order to get into
this place you have you just can't show
up and make and go in you can't even
make reservations like it's a restaurant
or something you have to know someone
who is a member and a member as far as I
understand it can be an actual magician
or someone who is just really into magic
and is willing to pay the dues to hang
out there
and rub shoulders with the magician's
you don't have to be a magician to be a
member no I think you either have to be
a magician or its acknowledged it's a
different type of member you probably
have to like write a paper about magic
or something to show your appreciation
this isn't nobody just gets into this
place you can be like an honorary member
I don't know what it's called but but we
know a member his name is Joel ward he
is a magician yeah and he was the magic
consultant on season one of buddy system
because Paige Kennedy acted in that as
Maxwell and his character puts on a
magic show when one of the episodes
well he's watched that he's a horrible
showman but he's a legitimate magic
maker like I wouldn't even call him a
magician he actually has magical
powered a wizard but he's a wizard but
he can't he has none of the showmanship
required to be an entertaining magician
we're gonna get into that we thought
that was ironic I thought that would be
funny right
but he had so even though he could do
real magic he could make a woman up he
could particulate a woman out of nothing
like make a person yeah
his magic consisted of doing really lame
tricks really underwhelming tricks but
he was actually doing the trick even
though and that was the distinction in
his own mind I still think it was funny
like tying a knot in a rope and then
pulling it and not disappears these are
like taking two rings and the difference
between me and other noises you watch
buddy system season one so we're
explaining it you should have the
difference between him and other
magicians was they're doing the same
thing the result is the same however
he's actually doing it yeah isn't that
funny but in order for him to actually
do it in that scene he had to be taught
how to do it as a trick as a because
he's not actually a wizard he's an actor
yeah
so Joel showed up under a tent at Venice
Beach because we were shooting another
scene there and Paige met him there and
like under a tent he taught him how to
do some magic tricks mm-hmm yeah and
then he and then he was there when we
were shooting he was still consulting
but he's like a legit magician and we
had to look him up because he we have to
have an inn and so he put us on the list
so to speak and then gave us granted us
access into the Magic Castle but it's
not that simple because you also gotta
have the proper dress code I mean they
send you this long email they really
keep this thing they try to keep it
pristine one of our friends one of our
friends had on pants that were not jeans
they were black dress pants but they
were Jean like and he actually had a
denim like quality he called ahead of
time and said I'm letting you know that
I am wearing black pants that look a
little bit like jeans but they're not
am I gonna be okay and the woman said
yes you'll be okay
turns out when he showed up I called it
oh he called ahead of time Wow
when he showed up the woman who was not
the woman he had spoken to on the phone
who was the woman that looks you up and
down to make sure that you are
acceptable into the castle uh-huh the
sorceress she said you can't come in oh
and he was like I called ahead of time
and spoke with name that will not be
spoken here eventually he worked it out
everything was okay he got in but just
it gives you a meme they take this
seriously so we knew it we had to dress
up the problem was we had a meeting we
had a meeting leading right up to coz
Mike wanted to get there when it opened
and he wanted to stay until it closed
which we were there from 5:00 p.m. until
1:30 a.m. can you believe that that's
never eight and a half hours never been
at any one thing that long not even work
we're the Magic Castle I'm pretty sure
we set a record well I'll tell you right
now I think we set a record for the most
fun that you can have at a Magic Castle
yeah well but we it was funny story
because we had to get dressed
we were at a meeting with Stevie only
the three of us were at a meeting on the
other side of town on the west side and
then we had to drive through the late
afternoon traffic to get back to the
Magic Castle trying to get there for
this very specific act that Mike wanted
to see at 5:00 p.m. and so we took our
suits with us yeah I'm talking suit
pants jacket button-up shirt tile dress
shoes the dress shoes is the only thing
you can wear yeah but we had to get
dressed in transit on the road because
we were running late and so Steve Steve
he's driving yeah and I mean because I
at one point I thought we were just
gonna take a lift or something to get
over there but then we were running so
late was just like Stevie we just need
you to take us we're like running back
to the car in the parking lot and like
talking her into taking us through the
the heart of Hollywood darkness I felt
more comfortable changing clothes in a
car with someone I knew then just like a
lyft driver that I've never met turns
out it's pretty difficult I mean I'm not
six foot seven yeah for you but in that
I was I was in the backseat it was it
was kind of difficult to change like I
mean I'm no magician but I was I thought
I could be a contortionist
once I started pulling that off yeah
like literally I was having to pull
things off but neither of us were able
to button our pants because well when
you're when you're doubled over and
you're putting on dress pants and you
know the dress pants that they got us in
these days oh they're so tight yeah you
know and I think I just think I'm still
growing who's they by the way who the
fashion mongers the people we submit
ourselves to and we have to get dressed
up yeah that's it the fashion mongers
they deal in fashion they say well that
I'm like in this too tight like I feel
like if I if I flex a quad I'm gonna I'm
gonna burst a seam like Bruce Banner
well it's like Nick Kroll Brooke is uh
busted as seen on a late-night show
recently because on Kimmel yeah because
the pants are too tight but it's also
very difficult to figure out how long
your tie is when you're seated and your
pants are untucked I mean in your shirt
is untucked well when you're doubled
over I think you're the the tip of your
tongue should touch your knee cast so I
had to keep I had to keep tying my tie
and then like standing up and in the
back of Stevie's car just to see where
it would hit me I had to retie my
tightest four times yeah but we could
not I mean so she finally gets us there
we're a little bit glad we have 50
minutes to get across town because I
needed every bit of it just to get ready
and that still didn't involve zipping
and buttoning the pants cuz we both get
out of her car and then we're like we're
getting our pants we get dropped off in
front of the Magic Castle
there's like a line of people who have
been waiting for this moment for their
entire life we get out and you start zip
tucking in and zipping up it's like
these guys are ready like an old man you
know how an old man he'll like it's just
the middle of the day it's like time to
read
cut my shirt in and an old man will just
unbutton and unzip and then start
putting going elbow deep pushing the
shirttail down yeah and then you know it
doesn't matter what you see it's all
covered yeah it's all covered you can't
you might see a little boxers action or
something that's what we were doing
we've now made our way into old age
because we are unapologetically zipping
and buttoning pants in public but we did
make it to the Magic Castle and we were
let in because we once we zipped up
tucked in and put the belt on you go to
the we look good and you go to the
reception area they look at your pants
make sure there's no Dedham quality to
them you give them your name or the name
and I said ok go over to this bookshelf
and say Open Sesame to the little owl
and you you go over there and you
whisper
Open Sesame right how mad you were yeah
and then the bookcase magically opens we
talked about this we're gonna get in
trouble because you can't we can't take
photos there's no so we couldn't take
photos you can take cameras in there you
can take your phones with you if you're
seen with your phone in picture mode I
don't know if they make you disappear I
don't know how it works but I didn't
sign anything I don't think yeah I
didn't check any boxes on the internet
even what we will talk about things and
we'll get specific at times but when we
feel like we're about to cross some line
of the magician's code we'll stop so
we're gonna let you know all about the
trip to the Magic Castle and how it is
affecting our minds and how we're
perceiving magicians these days and
there's their coolness this is not a
joke or lack thereof is serious yeah
but first we want to let you know that
we've got a new mug it is the mug that
sits before both of us that says good
luck with that
it just got it's got a cartoon version
of the Rambler wearing a tank top with
ironically the mythical logo which is
the Rambler on emblazoned upon it
he's given a thumbs-up good luck with
that it's something that we started to
say more here on your biscuits so we'll
probably keep saying it now that we're
selling a mug with it on it it's when
you when we like to give advice to
people and at the end of it we like to
say good luck with that because we know
that you should take all our advice with
a grain of salt it's also in the classic
Buies Creek elementary school colors
that is the blue and gold of the Buies
Creek demons where you played basketball
and I kept score for the women's
basketball team that's right
yeah everybody does their part good luck
with that
mythical dot store support entertainment
there's other stuff there too okay so so
here we go we're going into Magic Castle
we meet up with our friends I mean
there's like multiple bars there's
multiple levels you eat dinner there
it's at a certain point we had like a
private room because we signed up for
the Houdini seance which happens in this
room man I love nothing more well then
potentially magic we'll get to that but
besides that going out with a group of
my friends and then we we're seated at a
table that's round boy that makes me
happy because I stress out about Who am
I sitting next to and what conversations
am I just gonna be on the fringe of and
know that they're having a better
conversation than me but I can't quite
get into it it's not just around us at
the table the roundness of the table is
important but you also have to have the
private room yeah yeah you want to have
a group of 12 people have an open
conversation that everyone is a part of
which is what happened it was beautiful
oh yeah
a you need a 12-person round table in a
private room not always something that
can be arranged there's only a few
places in the world that have it Magic
Castle is one of them now I I will say
that this was my I believe it's my fifth
time going to the Magic Castle in the
six years that I've lived in Los Angeles
you sure it's not your fourth I guess
what I would think you
been for I've been 304 I've been with
I've been well I don't know I've been
with you and your parents mm-hmm which
is fabulous yeah then I went magical
then we went with Julian Smith the three
of us went mm-hmm and then hadn't we
gone before that too maybe it was your
fourth duck fifth time and then I went
back Christine I went back with my dad
and his wife and then I guess the fourth
time was the other night the other night
with Mike's party the first time I went
it was with your parents and and there
was one magician who we actually devoted
an entire episode of good mythical
morning I'm just remembering this -
talking about this magician that we saw
on the main stage who was this ultra
theatrical presentation involving a man
in a suit with a whole crap ton of doves
doves man he does never thought you can
make doves the truck exciting just
dumped it on us that's so many doves and
they were flying out of every or we were
enjoying the suit him creating doves out
of thin air so much that we both had a
laugh attack like there very few times
in my life have I enjoyed something so
thoroughly that I just began to to laugh
uncontrollably enter a land in euphoria
but you we were laughing because it was
there was an element of it that was
amazing that how can he be producing
doves to this with again and again and
again but then there was another part of
us laughing it was his style at his
style we were laughing it was we were it
was so cheesy yeah unbelievably cheesy
unbelievably cheesy I mean he would like
he would he would snap his head towards
us and like wink or like his eyes would
get big or his mouth would open for no
reason like he would have to come out
and there was a woman there was like a
want female assistant you know that was
weird and but it was just there was a it
was almost I would say a sad desperation
to it that made it poignant wow that's
harsh I mean it was it seems like
something in the music was like scored
in the 80s like 1982 and it had not
changed yeah it was old-school since
then but it what it was it was done so
sincerely he was sincere he wasn't being
ironic now I think this if you think it
was not cool there's a few things we
should say there's nothing cool about
just to give you the full picture to
expand on what you said earlier so
basically it's a mansion a very large
house that has a number of large rooms
that are basically you can see magicians
in different contexts everything from if
you go up to a bar a magician may come
up and just start interacting with you
and do magic for you right there
you can go to these parlors and they'll
be like a magician set up and like five
to ten people will kind of gather around
yeah and watch them do some magic but
then there there's a closed magic room
which probably holds 15 people so you're
really right in there watching a stadium
seating but just 15 people there's
another room that stadium seating that
has maybe 40 P 1435 and then there's
like a theater that's just flat and has
like chairs and it's got more of a stage
for doves and what and that's where dove
man was and whenever you go it's all
scheduled out you get you get a schedule
at the beginning of it can be different
magicians so and there's also a
restaurant that's the big table so you
also have a meal if you want so we had
the meal all the shows and then this
seance at the end of the night but I've
never seen the same magician there twice
in the four times that I've gone it's
because people come through LA and then
they do their magic and they and I'm
under the impression these magicians are
traveling far and wide doing their thing
or their things turns out there's a lot
of different things under the umbrella
of magic there is
well I wanted to set that stage just for
a second just to give people the full
picture of what we experienced but uh
huh I do think it's important to
establish the baseline of how we think
about magicians before we start talking
about what we experienced that feels
like the the best way to do it well I
think the Dove man was that's that's a
data point definitely another data point
before that is just everything on
television I mean I even heard someone
talking about it in our last trip to the
Magic Castle so I was like man I just
keep thinking about it rest development
and job was a was a magician of sorts
and well not of sorts he was a magician
if I remember correctly and he was very
I mean he is still on that that's true
the carrot you know his his onstage
persona was like very self serious and
dramatic in a similar way to the Dove
guy like I mean very sharp looks and
sharp movements and it's very easy to
parody because it no self-awareness it's
almost a parody of itself
now confession I've had this perception
about magicians for quite some time that
I will enjoy a magic show especially
like a close magician doing something I
like giving myself over to the illusion
and at no point am i tempted to think
the actual magic is happening but I love
thinking and the artistry the
craftsmanship that goes into how many
hours were put into getting this trick
right so that it looks like magic like I
love that but at the same time I've
always thought this is not for me I am
separate from this I am here to observe
but I don't want to cross the line and
be the magician because I think less of
them okay that's the traditional
disposition that I've brought to this in
fact my son was once at Disneyland and
is a magic shop in the Magic Kingdom
okay which makes all kinds of sense
doesn't and he went in there and he was
like dad can I get this magic trick and
I said son you don't want to be the kid
who does magic you know I feel no let me
say I feel bad about this you can talk
to me about how bad of a parent I am I
typically don't do this such a touch
like your dad thing I feel bad about it
especially based on how I think now okay
but I didn't I have a perception I have
carried a perception of magicians and I
didn't want my son to fall into that
category and I thought that maybe if he
gets one trick it's all he needs is a
pretty low he's got a magic show with
doves at the Magic Castle which I won't
go in half I will enjoy but I don't want
to be directly related to right do you
know what I mean you don't want that in
your own house yeah because that's
because so you see where I'm coming from
I mean that's it I can I confess that me
and we wrote a character that we thought
it was funny to make mommy we've already
been through it but it was you know we
just saw the comedy and like the lack of
self-awareness that you need in order to
fully commit to being a magician so so
yeah I mean I've shared that sentiment I
mean you actually introduced me to a
friend of yours back home who was a was
a magician also named Michael and he
could do some I mean the up-close magic
that he could do was so impressive very
impressive mind-blowing yeah but I mean
my observation is that it's a certain
personality type that I mean I'm not
gonna again it's like I feel like this
is tough right I don't want to be a jerk
we are jerks we are jerks okay bye
but looking down our nose and saying I'm
cooler than that so I'm just I
we are owning it right you know it's
it's like saying okay like a soundman is
a certain type of person like if you if
you work in touring environments enough
you know there's a certain personality
profile associated with the person
behind the soundboard and I'm gonna use
that as an example of just you know it's
it's it's not about being cool or not
being cool this about a certain type of
profession is a certain subset of
personalities and I'd you know I think
that's what magicians are like that you
know and I I think you know it's kind of
a kin to like a band kid you know like
okay I play the saxophone and again i'm
not i'm i i applaud band kids i tried to
be one and i failed
played trumpet in seventh grade but but
to make it all the way through the
orchestra i think there's certain
personality types that excel at that
okay what you're talking about
is exactly the subject of this article
that Feldman pulled up this was an
Esquire article that mostly talked about
the magician dynamo who's apparently a
really big magician in England okay and
Jim Merritt wrote this article back in
2015 so a few years old a few quotes
from this cool kids don't become
magicians because it requires being
alone in your bedroom for hours and
hours practicing magic tricks mm-hmm now
the name of this article by the way is
will magicians ever be seen as cool and
it centers around this guy dynamo who is
kind of trying to break the mold a
little bit and then it all it talks
about David Blaine who is probably the
best example of someone trying to be
anti magician mm-hmm but then he goes on
to basically say that even David Blaine
who we've actually seen do magic in
person and it claims
literally two feet away yeah and it made
my pants but he's but the point of the
article is that while he is not cool he
is cool he's not actually cool is what
this guy says now let me let me continue
with this there's something irredeemably
geeky about the kind of play magicians
are involved in says Lev Grossman author
of fantasy and fantasy novel The
Magicians they're engaged in a kind of
public childlike make-believe I don't
think that could ever be cool or even
that it should be it's interesting
because he mentioned geekery which I
mean geekery has become a has become a
lane of cool mm-hmm
and so if magician Rhee is a subset of
geekery did geekery bring it up closer
to the surface and all the way into
coolness well okay let me continue
there's a couple other points that I
want you to consider he continues the
thing about magician but can I just
summarize that other point so you're
telling me that he says that because
it's a public display it's it's it's
childlike
its childlike in terms of your
suspension of disbelief and I mean is it
acting
well okay go ahead okay the thing about
magicians which defines them is that
they know things we don't Lev says which
is also true of cool people they
understand things that the rest of us
don't and never will a cool magician
it's a double negative we can give
magicians everything else money fame and
attention but they can't be cool you
have you can have magic or you can be
cool but you can't have both that's his
theory I don't know what to say to that
I mean it's so what so it's we can't
give them the power of coolness because
then they'll have everything well he
goes on to talk about how there is a
sense of I think the most compelling
part of this is that the thing that
draws people to you
and again I'm not saying this is right
I'm just saying that our society has
deemed certain people cool and typically
they deem people who play sports as
being cool which I don't I don't agree
with that I'm just saying that that is
and I do and I do agree with you that
that is changing right I mean the whole
geek culture has shifted that somewhat
but traditionally it's like okay if you
do things that are social that usually
that kind of show your dominance in
front of people whereas the skills
required to become a magician do involve
kind of being alone spending a lot of
time mastering this thing but I think
that maybe this last thing I think it's
about authenticity perhaps that's why
magic and cool can never mix at some
base level we sense that the people who
do magic are often seeking something
attention street cred power and there's
no quicker way to derail social
acceptance than by appearing to want it
and want it really really bad and above
all there's the elephant in the room
that no amount of smoke mirrors or
branded Footwear can conceal when it
comes to cool the currency is
authenticity and nothing magician to do
is real III think that that's an
interesting theory I think a much
simpler one to also consider is that I
think the tricks themselves if you're if
you're really good at it are mind
blowing
like Joel took us aside our whole group
just impromptu and he sat down and he
started doing card tricks right there in
front of us
and they were absolutely amazing we were
we were like screaming you were like
loved it you were like dancing you're
like doing hiney I wanted to run away
was come back repeatedly it was it was
he district' us so hard and he's a and
he's a very good performer
I think the intersection between the
skill to develop a really good illusion
or really good tricks or whatever to
pull that off and to blow people
minds and also to adopt a demeanor of
performance those are two totally
different skillsets to like be an
interpersonal performer to adopt a
character even or the lack of a
character in order to draw people in or
entertain people it's it's a it's a
different skill set than being really
good at the trick itself and so to be
good at both of those things I think is
really difficult they may actually be
opposed because I think to be really
good at magic tricks there's a level of
self-awareness that you might have to
chuck out but then you really have to
like I think a lot of the best actors I
mean have a lot of neuroses as far as
like self-awareness but I think that's
the beautiful thing about it I I think
that the my operating thesis at this
point in the conversation is that
magicians aren't cool and they shouldn't
be and it would ruin it if they were and
I don't want them to be and when I say
cool I'm using the traditional
understanding of what society is being
so I could actually say that they
actually are cool if cool means awesome
you know what I'm saying
so because what because what I will say
is that they they if you try if you're
trying well I think this is kind of what
the articles gonna if you're trying
really really hard to be like relevant
well it you can tell you're already
doing this magic thing which is this
super attention-getting thing if you're
doing it and you're like wearing these
cool clothes or whatever and you're
trying to be like super cool in your
approach
it seems to try hard you just can't you
can't go all the way it's good the
authenticity is all is already in
question when you're doing something
that's you're purposely deceiving people
that's part of your act you might as
well have this caricatured approach to
it that shows that there isn't a
self-awareness that's what makes it
great like we got to talk about zabrocki
okay yeah I think how you talk about you
because here's the thing we should tell
that store
as a case study in what I believe is the
coolest magician that I have ever
experienced
in a room with me yeah but before I do I
I will just say that to piggyback on
what you're saying I started to think
about stand-up comedians because there's
some similarities like the thing about
they have a microphone they're on a
stage they're basically saying I want I
want to entertain you I want I want you
to like what I'm saying and respond to
it it has that it could have that
desperate feel of please respond to me
and the comedians that seem desperate
the the comedians that seem like they're
doing a routine it's hard to make that
they're the ones that don't work that's
not cool the comedians that are cool are
the comedians that you just think that
it feels like they're just saying this
stuff directly from their heart but
that's a certain type of comedian
there's a whole other group of there's
many different categories of stand-up
comedians that don't like a joke
basically don't do the authentic thing
but they do many different things and
I'm not just talking about like
something as cheesy as like prop comedy
but that yeah there's many different
lanes but prop comedy moves into now
we've got a Venn diagram but magicians
and prop comedians right and there's
crossover in the props and neither of
them are cool prop carrot top is not
cool when he tried to get buff and get
cool it got worse you know I'm saying I
should have went further into not being
cool would you bet him more entertaining
precisely what I'm here but I there's a
lot more stand-up comedians who figure
out the persona in a way that's like man
that that that person is cool versus in
my limited experience I have a theory
that there's a much lower percentage of
magicians who have succeeded at adopting
a cool persona then a stand-up comedians
that you went into from that article
yeah but we did experience somebody that
I would say on a scale of 0
100% authentically like when something's
really when somebody's really cool you
have this sinking feeling that you feel
like you don't have it that's what
really makes somebody cool it really
taps into your own insecurities whatever
they may be I think that's a component
of discerned coolness and I'd
experienced that with this guy before he
humiliated me in front of everybody
zou brekkie is his name and we we saw
him Mike had done research on this guy
somehow he knew that this guy was good
and and he was telling us and I was like
I looked at Christie and I rolled my
eyes I was like no get your hopes up I
mean it is in the close up magic room
which where the best things happen yeah
well and a little little funny aside if
something that happened in the in that
room is we go into the room you have to
stand in line because there's a lot of
demand for different acts and so we're
standing in line for the probably half
an hour for a minute we were there for
eight and a half hours so that didn't
know if that was a blink of an eye so
we're standing there waiting and and
then we I go I'm one of the last people
to come into the room and I see that
there's way more people in the room than
there are seats but I also notice that
Jason sudakis and Olivia Wilde are
sitting in the middle and this is where
there's like 12 seats in this room and
then I also see Nathan from Nathan for
you they're all in the room you also saw
me and then from rhettandlink link is
standing up but the real celebrities are
seated and one of the guys in our group
who's the most likely in our group to
confront in this way who said he was
upset that we've been waiting in line
and then we walk in there and then
they're seated and we don't have a seat
and of course I'm like that's Jason
Sudeikis and Olivia honestly I'm not
gonna say anything I'll stand up that's
fine I'm not gonna say anything but you
were you heard him you were that you
heard him say this What did he say to
them I would say to them he said it sort
of out well as will come into play later
III had had some something to drink I
was a bit I was a little inebriated it
wasn't milk
so I wasn't what all of my attention was
not honed on him at this moment but I
was my attention was drawn to him when
he started in a loud voice saying to
whoever in the room would listen that
he's not a celebrity and he doesn't have
a seat but he was like I may not be
famous but I was what I would did wait
for about half an hour at that point my
attention was drawn to him and I shushed
him he was like I was like I don't want
Jason sudakis and Olivia while to know
that I'm with you
so I shushed him as you would shush a
stranger but that blew over pretty
quickly and then zabrze he came out yes
I'm standing I'm standing there kind of
in the back wait and wait you were
further down I was on the right side two
people in front of you down that's right
so stadium seating he comes he parts of
curtain comes and sits down and this guy
has like a gaunt face like a very very
thin face like you can see like the
outline of his skull and he looks like
he was I like bones a butler for The
Addams Family deep-set eyes tuxedo
piercing gaze he sits down doesn't say
anything and just looks around the room
and he had this like a eye quality to
him like an automaton like animatronic
animatronic like he was looking around
without blinking and then he just starts
to speak in a way not much different
than this and sometimes he would say
jokes without changing his intonation or
expression at all it was beautiful right
from the beginning I was like this man
is a master strong comedic choice with
100% commitment that unwavering
unwavering and immediately gripped me as
cool I mean he hadn't done one trick but
he was kind of scary
he didn't he he was confident he didn't
there was no searching for acceptance
and he just commanded the room
and that's cool it man if you can walk
and sit down and say hardly anything if
the in the okay here's the thing in the
broad definition of cool I'm 100% in
agreement it's amazingly cool because
it's amazingly awesome for all the
reasons that you just stated but in the
traditional understanding of like like
if somebody was like is he a cool guy
I'd be like mmm let me explain some
things about him he's not normal he's
weird but weird good and weird good is
cool do you know what I'm saying well he
was also a character I I didn't think
that that was totally him no did we
talked to him after after the seance cuz
he did our seance and I think while he
was still in character somewhat I think
he also was be I think he's just he was
amping up himself he's it wasn't he's an
extension he's an eccentric dude in a
very good way I love everything about
his act he seems like a really cool guy
but the tradition he's not like if
somebody said is he you know you know
what I'm getting at he's not the
traditional understanding of cool he's
beyond cool and I don't want I feel like
I'm diminishing him by calling him cool
because he's beyond cool did he he did
the feather on the nose trick with Lisa
and Caroline right yeah cuz I think this
is one of the first tricks that stood
out he brought the to it and they're
both from our group up like facing each
other at the tables and then he was in
the middle and he got them to close
their eyes and then he took a feather
and he went any touch Lisa's nose and
then he said if I just touched your nose
raise your hand and they both raised
their hand and then he he kept doing it
he'd never and we never came close to
touching Caroline here's the thing
anywhere with anything has to believe
that the way this trick works is that he
is at some point touching touching both
people in the same place that's my guess
I could not see it and I knew the new to
be looking for it cuz he knows that's
what you're gonna say he did it five
times so after the second time
your your your watching both people
intently but to see if he's touched but
let me tell him my perspective of this
trick he did with you so at one point he
was like he'd begun he began looking
around the room and is he made eye
contact with me and immediately pass by
me it looked at the person thanks to me
impact and then he looks at Lincoln
there's there's twinkle in his eyes it's
like I'm going to speak with this man
he's like you sir and at that point I
was in a daze I think I was kind of
looking down and at nothing all you had
to do the the basis of the trick is he
takes a book and he begins flipping
through the pages of the book and link
is supposed to say stop and then he's
supposed to stop on the page that he's
at and then the trick proceeds well that
took seven minutes with blink ha okay
well yeah well you started flipping the
book and he was like tell me when to
stop
oh yeah and I might say stop I said stop
and he would be done with the book and
they were laughing no no no this is how
long it would be he would be like all
you have to do is tell me when to stop
then even go and then you would say stop
but you're trying to present it as if he
did wasn't doing that on purpose that
that was just me being a numbskull
I mean it was a little bit about it was
doing it he knew that it he magically
could get to the end of the book before
I could get you he could see and you
were saying things like I know what
you're trying to do and I liked it which
by the way Olivia Wilde thought was alia
I mean I was looking at a living a while
the whole time and the whole time most
of the time and you know I mean it was
test I was tastefully doing it like when
he was working with you I looking at an
excuse to look back and she was just two
people from you so I looked at her
instead of looking at you and she loved
you man you should have talked to her
later because she has got a big kick out
of you well I finally said stop while
they were still paid his turning and he
stops and then he he it's like a novel
looking book like a creepy looking book
and he he starts walking towards me you
know
and he's like okay I want you to
remember the page number and the word in
the upper left hand corner of the book
underneath right underneath the page
number and you said no I did not say I
did not say it out loud oh you didn't
say it I didn't say it out loud because
I wasn't gonna tell him I had never had
to remember it and then he did some
other tricks he did something else and
then he gave he gave me the book at that
point and he did some other tricks and
then he's like okay now back to you sir
he's like find the page that you
remember from earlier and I started
flipping I use my phone and the light on
my phone in order to see cuz it was so
dark in there I'm like fumbling for my
phone and then I'm fumbling to turn the
pages and the page number was 223 it was
like a 400 page book man it's not easy
to find 223 it took me a long time and
everybody thought it was really funny
90 seconds that I mean find the page you
know that the numbers are in order
like that's typically can zero in on
that brief he did a mind trick on me
where I couldn't find the page and then
I'm like I'm sorry this is taking so
long
I think you're doing this to me or
something I don't know what I said then
I finally find 220 221 222 and I finally
find like I found it and then I look and
the page is ripped out of the book I'm
like it's not here it's been ripped out
of the book and then he points to the
wall there was a frame a framed picture
that has page 223 ripped out and behind
the frame and he was like read the word
and Lisa goes up and reads 223 Dandi or
something like a B shadow word was
shabby anyway in it it was amazing again
magic tricks are not the type of thing
that you describe on a podcast and then
your mind is long you kind of have to be
there yeah right
no that was probably
of us I think this but it was
mind-blowing but in addition to that the
way he was able to manipulate me to be
the butt of the joke and I had there was
no escaping it there was nothing I could
do in order to not fall into his trap no
matter what I did he would have had a
way to make it funny and everybody was
you know and the more people laughed the
more I was like fumbling for the page
and he constructed a brilliant comedy
routine and it was using me as a subject
and it was cool now
okay so zabrocki is the pinnacle right
so Breck he's the pinnacle for us I
started to rethink everything now let me
just take a short aside and I'm gonna I
found this forum where the question was
asked in 2007 magician's attire what do
you wear and then presumably magicians
began to answer what they wear and so in
contrast is a brekkie so here's what I
want this is my premise not all
magicians are cool no no no no no just
being a great magician does not make you
cool it's how you're a magician
it's a brekkie cool let me give you some
examples of what I consider not cool in
their own words so the question was what
do you wear when you go out and perform
magic okay one guy says I just wear my
regular style of clothes which in my
case is the whole skater look okay okay
skater boy no the guy says I usually
wear a regular white tee and jeans with
a lot of pockets just picture that for a
second yeah okay that's great jeans with
a lot of pockets
okay give me another word usually when I
get the chance to go out and perform for
friends I'm wearing my everyday stuff
you know bootcut jeans and an affliction
shirt or something I'm not making this
up an affliction shirt or something I
wear a t-shirt jeans almost every time
unless I go to a wedding or something
like that
sunglass is a watch and my Eagle ring
every time Eagle ring every time okay
this is not what I expected
I'm not done I thought you gonna say
like I wear a bow tie in a tux
then I'm in a top hat these are guys who
are trying so hard to be cool to be cool
and is it working I'm just talking about
it it's 11 years ago on a forum and
you're see can you sense the uncool
nests
let me continue when performing
professionally I wear a nice button-up
shirt jeans and sometimes a fedora yes
of course sometimes once in a while I
get really all out and wear a gray vest
and necktie over it yeah we can wear
everyday performances I just wear baggy
jeans and a t-shirt my another guy my
modus operandi you feel horrible
laughing not people you know no I listen
no this is important my modus operandi
is to go one step above who I'm
performing for for casual performances
I'm normally in jeans slash cargo pants
and a tee with a short sleeve shirt on
top in the summer shorts all the way can
you imagine a magician in shorts well
that's two more sleeves to pull
something out of doves are flying out of
the thigh area now okay guys all right
yeah what you said not withstanding I do
agree I'm not trying to make fun of
people for the way they dress even
though that's what I just did
what I'm saying is is that there is look
I mean there is no world in which cargo
pants are cool I mean it's just that's
it it's superficial it's shallow
it doesn't ultimately matter it's a
privilege
just be able to make that observation
they're functional they do have a lot of
pockets maybe you can put things like
scarves and handkerchiefs and balls that
you're gonna take out and blow people's
minds why don't we dub what if he pulled
like really nonsensical memes out of
your pocket but let me tell you right
now this is a brekkie my friend was not
wearing anything like this he was in
this very cool black suit with a simple
white shirt he had on black dress pants
he looked like a magician and I'm saying
he is no mess so right wait no it wasn't
cheesy he didn't have a top hat on
fedora weird glasses that are obviously
for effect he just looked like a person
that would command your attention and
let me also say that our good friend and
our connection to the whole Magic Castle
mr. Joel Ward totally different thing
going on he's not he he doesn't look
like he should be a butler for the Adams
family he just looks like a nice guy
and he just had on a nice friendly
unassuming guy he just had a nice gray
suit on with a white shirt again he
didn't like he was trying too hard and
he didn't look like he was trying to not
try hard he didn't have shorts on he
wouldn't gotten into Magic Castle if he
did but you see what I'm saying if he
were if he was putting on that suit on
the drive to the Magic Castle to meet us
he probably would have had to zip and
button it once he got out - and an
exhibit because it fit Exhibit B there
is actually a guy that Feldman found
cool magician calm are you serious this
guy has self-proclaimed that he is a
cool magician and I've just done a
cursory look at his website which is in
Comic Sans font there we go and I know
that he's not cool okay
I just listen nothing against a guy but
I think my whole point is that magicians
are cool but not because they're trying
to be cool not because they're giving
tips and forums on how to seem cool
because an affliction t-shirt hello even
at 20 2007 wasn't cool it was
never cool hold on I've seen you in some
of those shirt I never had an affliction
shirt you had you had knockoff of
fliction button-ups and it wasn't cool
at the time you had them too
you told me that when we did online
nation in 2007 that I wore all that
stuff and then we brought up the promo
pictures and you had the same stuff on
it was a wardrobe person who thought it
was cool it wasn't cool I thought it was
cool it wasn't cool 2007 the same year
so it's not we're not saying we're cool
just cuz you know what's gonna make you
cool I'm saying magicians are cool but
they're cool they're beyond cool the
ones that aren't cool are the ones that
are trying to be cool saying that
they're cool and departing from the
tradition of just dressing like a
magician just do it just embrace it be
weird you're trying to deceive people
you're doing things that stretch the
limits of people's imagination just
embrace that and build off of that well
the thing that I tried to grow into as a
human through that experience was to
experience the artistry of it I mean
there was the guy on the main stage who
was very cheesy it was like very Disney
theme park he like had the fake glasses
and he had a he acted like he was in an
attic and he was creeping around did you
sense desperation and ever he never
talked and it was as if the creepy attic
was doing magic on him so he was
constantly he had a mime quality which
you know is very problematic and then he
was you know he was producing things
using a mirror which was that that act
in itself was cool like that trick that
trick not the act the drink was cool his
tricks were all of his tricks worked no
trick that I saw attempted the entire
night at the Magic Castle failed or or
even that I could think oh I know how
that was done they all legitimately had
skills I knew how the
Shadow Puppets were done yeah there was
a guy who did Shadow Puppets with his
hand that was absolutely amazing it
wasn't actually magic what on that part
and did you sense I didn't sense any
desperation I mean let me just say I
think the thing that's cool is when you
don't sense the desperation that
someone's really trying really hard I do
you think it's really hard to do man it
is but isn't that what every magician
should strive for and I think they are I
just think it's that difficult because
again you're not you're not gonna clear
all magicians cool though are you know
I'm seeing because all magicians can't
be cool and because they they I agree
that they don't need to be cool I was
actually just trying to appreciate the
artistry associated with not only can
this guy do this really convincing magic
trick to make his glasses disappear and
then reappear on the other side of this
mirror but he put together an entire
story which was without seeing a word I
understood that this Disney character
dude was in a creepy attic and magic was
happening to him and he was getting
freaked out and then he became a
millionaire because every time he would
put money bags in front of a mirror when
he reached behind it he would have
double the money back then he would put
it in that hand and then he would do it
again and before you knew it he had like
16 bags where was he hiding all those
bags magic man that's a great trick
great trick but the theme was a bit kid
Z but he did create a world within which
he told a story and that is his art you
know it wasn't exactly for me but I did
appreciate how he went he went in for it
he went all in I appreciated it I'm just
saying that if I'm critiquing it
I didn't cringe which is what I am doing
right now and again I don't have
necessarily any right to do this I'm
just doing it I'm just saying that it
was the part where it seemed like I
could I don't want to think when I'm
watching a movie I don't want to be
taken out of the illusion that it's a
story and start thinking about the film
making so when there's badly-written
lines when there's badly delivered lines
when there's badly shot shots that takes
you out in the moment because you can
see the effort of filmmaking right right
and the same thing applies to all
artistry the moment it's really like
you're trying
especially when it's live when you're in
a room with 19 other people and the
performer I mean you you really feel the
tension if they're not commanding and if
they're not if they're not confident
when you can see somebody imploding oh
gosh yeah you know what I'm saying and I
feel for these people I'm just saying
that as our oblivious
oblivious to the fact that I'm no longer
that's not connecting yeah that it's not
connecting I mean and that's why I draw
the comparison to a stand-up comic which
you know but both of these take a
tremendous amount of guts and skill and
artistry and I think it's it's it's it's
unfortunate that we're viewing this
through the lens of is it cool or not I
think but I think what we closed it
again I think we've established unless
people aren't listening
this is not a superficial of analysis of
magicians this is just thinking about it
through the lens of what people
traditionally think is cool and then
maybe redefining that I'm just making
the point that same magician is like
same stand-up comedian but there's so
many different types of stand-up comics
so many different styles and there's so
many different styles of magicians that
it's unfair to to critique them under
that such a broad heading you know the
challenge with both is to create an act
that connects and that is skilled to
make you you know the stand-up comic to
assume a character and that may be the
most authentic version of you it may be
a totally fabricated version of a
character but it needs to connect with
flesh-and-blood in a physical space and
you know I've never had the guts to try
you to one
honestly because it's extremely
difficult and I think magic is so much
harder because I think the starting
point of stand-up comics is this like
edgy coolness and then you know you can
lose that but you get some cool points
for even being on that stage all along
with just a microphone yeah but but when
you bring props or then you start and
then you move further than the Venn
diagram to just bring in a top hat with
a rabbit in it so to speak or dove
you've really got your work cut out for
you yeah so it's a you know we enjoyed
every minute of every single
presentation but some of it we enjoy for
different reasons than they intended and
if I was only basing my enjoyment on
what I considered cool in the
traditional sense I wouldn't have had a
good time so what I'm saying is if
you're getting if you're if you're
getting into magic because you want to
be cool it's a huge uphill battle forget
about it
don't make that your goal don't seek to
be viewed in a traditionally like
esteemed way to do magic do magic to
blow people's freaking minds and then
don't try too hard
to look like you're fitting in
especially I don't know what the
equivalent of an affliction shirt is
right now and I'd really don't know what
an Eagle ring is I have reason to
believe that the ego ring is probably
cool even still yeah whatever the
equivalent of an affliction shirt is
right now don't wear that when you do
magic because you look like you're
trying too hard
just dress in an unassuming way let your
magic speak for itself because to get
back to the question our magician is
actually cool yes they can be
but not in the way that you're thinking
I think is much more about check it's
checking yourself as an audience member
beforehand you know we have the night of
our lives because we made up our minds
that we were going to accept it all for
what it was and find beauty and
entertainment in all of it cool or not
and we saw we we ran the gamut if you're
so concerned about being cooled and miss
you're gonna you're gonna you're gonna
miss out if you want to be cool you
can't even say start a band anymore
because starting a band is not cool
anymore unfortunately like having a jam
band and playing the guitar now that's
not cool if you want to be cool you got
to be a frickin DJ right you got to get
like turntables that's probably too old
now yeah I don't even and I don't know
what's cool anymore I don't try to keep
up with it I'm just saying that there
are certain paths to it and don't worry
about just do magic man so I think what
I'm gonna have to do is I want to go
home and I'm gonna tell Locke you know
it's been it's been six or seven years
and I'm gonna have to be like son you
want to go to that magic shop and get a
trick now don't do it be cool cuz it's
not but it could be fun
check out the brekkie I'm gonna give a
shout-out to him man check check he has
a Twitter I'm a little afraid to say
watch videos on YouTube I don't know if
they exist but I just don't think that
how you can watch people react to magic
on YouTube but I don't think you're
supposed to watch magic on YouTube it's
just the be in the room with the guy
give mesmerised
it's great he's guy he's got a Twitter
go follow him there
Rob's a breckman look at that link look
at his frickin Twitter icon he looks
like he's a stirrer he's an astronaut
Robertson brekkie it's a brekkie za bre
CKY thanks thanks Iraqi for giving us a
great night man it's fabulous we'll be
back we'll be back if you're there we'll
be back anyway I'll be back anyway man I
love it get dressed up and thank you -
Joel ward he blew our minds that night
oh yeah with some magic that we couldn't
even begin to figure out he was dressed
perfectly except for what he was doing
and he's an incredible magician so shout
out to Joel as well let us know what you
think hashtag ear biscuits and hey you
got a friend of yours who's into magic
or hates magic for both those reasons
share this episode we appreciate when
you get the ear biscuits out there for
other people to listen to draw them into
the fold and take their wallets no is
that what magicians don't do that those
are pickpockets yeah but I'm sure they
some magicians are big pockets and some
pickpockets or magicians sleight of hand
type situation yep all right thanks for
hanging out with us will speak at you
again next week
[Music]